my dad uh when he got sober I said Dad  are you going to stay sober the rest of  your life  this is where the power of one more  comes in my dad says uh I don't know I  can tell you this I'm going to stay  sober for one more day  and so when I went through that my dad  called me I was really broke my dad goes  you thinking about quitting and I go  yeah I'm close he goes  don't quit for one more day I didn't and  that not quitting for one more day and  holding on would go to the next day into  the next day but there were these  glimpses in my life where it's like you  know what I may not be the smartest or  the best talker I definitely don't have  the highest IQ I'm not the tallest dude  or the strongest dude or the best  looking dude or any of that but um I'm  not going to get out worked I'm going to  outwork you I'm going to do one more rep  in the gym I'm gonna do one more phone  call I'm gonna do one more email I'm  gonna do one more text